سانجاي لديك مقال جديد
حول هذا الأمر حقًا يتعلق بتأثير
أسلحة نمط AR-15 على جسم
الإنسان وتتحدث عن كيف علمك أستاذك في
كلية الطب عن
تأثير الأسلحة النارية المختلفة على
جسم الإنسان باستخدام البطيخ ماذا
هل تعلمت نعم ،
كان هذا قبل حوالي 30 عامًا
وكانت تجربة لا تمحى إلى حد ما أعتقد
بالنسبة لمعظمنا نحن طلاب الطب الذين أخذونا
في اليوم الأخير من هذه
المحاضرة الخاصة إلى ميدان بندقية
مع مسدسات وبنادق
وأطلقوا النار بشكل أساسي على  يجلس البطيخ فوق
البراميل لإعطائنا فكرة عن
الفرق بالضبط بين هذه
الأسلحة النارية
المختلفة وكان شيئًا
تعرفه حقًا وأعتقد أنه عالق معنا جميعًا
بالطريقة التي تجعلك إظهار الرئتين السوداء
حقًا لا ترغب في ذلك  دخان ،
نظرت إلى مسدس ، رأيت أن
البطيخ به جرح مدخل في
جرح مخرج مثل ماثيو كان يتحدث
عنه بمسدس ، كانت الجروح
بنفس الحجم الذي يمكن رؤيته
شطف الجلد على مدخل
الجرح إلى الداخل والشطف للخارج
على جرح الخروج ولكن نوعًا خطيًا من
مسار حجم الرصاصة
مع AR-15 أو بندقية
في هذه الحالة رأيت
جرحًا مدخلًا ربما كان
حجمًا مشابهًا ولكن  رأيت جرح
خروج كان أكبر بكثير ولكن داخل
البطيخ عندما فتحنا ذلك
البطيخ رأينا أنه قد
تم حفره وكان هناك الكثير من الطاقة
التي تم نقلها بالفعل داخل
البطيخ لدرجة أنها مجرد نوع من تمزيق
جميع الأنسجة بداخلها  هذا ما
يحدث ، لقد رأيت للتو الفرق في
القوة هناك رطل من القوة
بين مسدس ، السرعة والطاقة
الخارجة من ذلك مقابل
بندقية مختلفة تمامًا ، وغالبًا ما يكون لدى الناس
فكرة خاطئة مفادها أنني مرة أخرى العديد من
الأشخاص الذين يدرسون هذه الأنواع من  تتفهم الأشياء
ولكن الذخيرة نفسها غالبًا ما تكون أصغر
في واحدة من هذه البنادق من طراز ar15 الأكبر حجمًا
في المسدس ، فالأمر كله يتعلق
بالسرعة وأن السرعة تخلق
الكثير من الاختلاف  إن الطاقة داخل
الجسم والتي تسبب هذه الأنواع من الإصابات
التي
يتحدث عنها ماثيو والآخرون عن سانجاي ، تتحدث أيضًا عن
وقتك في الإبلاغ وحتى العمل
في العراق ، ما الذي تعلمته هناك ،
نعم أنت تعلم أنه مثير للاهتمام عندما
كنت هناك  وعندما كنت
أنهي مدرسة الطب ، كان هناك حظر
على هذه الأنواع من
هذه الأنواع من الأسلحة من نوع ar-15 في
الولايات المتحدة ، لذلك لم نشاهد الكثير
من هذه الأنواع في المستشفيات ، لذلك في المرة الأولى التي
رأيت فيها هذه الأنواع  من الإصابات على
جسد حقيقي ، لم يكن البطيخ قد انتهى
في صخرة
، وأعني أنه كان مرة أخرى هذا
الشيء الذي لا يمحى ، مارك بييلا ، وهو
المصور وأنا ، وهناك أشياء
لا تزال تعرف صعوبة التحدث عنها
ولكنك تعرف متى  عندما ترى
سلاحًا ، فإن سلاحًا ناريًا من هذا القبيل يمكن أن
يفجر أحد أطراف الجسم تمامًا أو
في البداية عندما يأتي هؤلاء المرضى ،
لم نكن متأكدين مما إذا كان قد
تم إطلاق النار عليهم أو ما إذا كانوا
ضحية لليد أو  غرينا  دي انفجار أو
شيء من هذا القبيل كان صعبًا في
بعض الأحيان ثم العودة إلى
الولايات التي تعرفها في منتصف الجزء الذي
تعرفه في العقد الماضي وبدأت في رؤية
هذه الأنواع من الإصابات في مدينتي الأصلية
التي كانت مذهلة للغاية